nokia où on est la réunion entre edouard
philippe et les partenaires sociaux
alors cette réunion entre les
organisations syndicales patronales
edouard philippe la ministre du travail
mme muriel pénicaud ainsi que le
secrétaire d'état chargé des retraites
devrait s'achever dans quelques minutes
je rappelle qu'elle a démarré à 9h alors
quatre sujets ont été abordés la
pénibilité la la fin de carrière pour
les seniors parce qu'on imagine qu'on ne
va pas exercé son métier à 60 comme à 30
le minimum des pensions
et puis également la transition entre
les 42 régimes spéciaux au système
universel alors un mot sur la pénibilité
qui fait débat depuis plusieurs semaines
actuellement le système permet certaines
professions de partir des 57 ans or ce
nouveau projet permettrait de partir
seulement à 60
et puis il ya la question du qui
détermine la pénibilité d'une d'une
profession et bien cette décision
pourrait être confiée aux branches
professionnelles et là c'est le medef
qui s'y opposent en estimant que ce
serait un retour aux régimes spéciaux
et il ya aussi une question de catégorie
4 catégories de pénibilité ne seront pas
incluses dans ce projet notamment par
exemple le port de charges lourdes donc
vous voyez que de nombreux sujets de
désaccord persistent et ne serait ce que
sur ce sujet de la pénibilité je vous
propose d'écouter deux présidents de
syndicats que nous avons interviewé
juste avant le début de la réunion
aujourd'hui nous savons que même si la
pénibilité est prise en compte
ah le fait référence et c'est d'ailleurs
pareil pour les carrières longues ah ce
fameux hd qui libre qui reste dans le
texte version longue et donc ça veut
dire que les personnes même s'ils
partiront deux ans avant devront quand
même faire deux ans de plus et donc nous
la cftc en demandent à ce que les
carrières longues et les gens je les
travaux pénibles sur lequel on ne peut
rien faire au niveau des conditions de
travail ni du reclassement puissent
continuer à partir à 60 ans dans le
privé ou avant dans votre régime
la problématique reste cesse la
référence à l'âge des équilibres
eller évidemment sur la pénibilité même
si on doit prendre en compte il ya de
réelles avancées sur l'amélioration des
conditions de travail sur le
reclassement pour les personnes qui
pourraient avoir une formation
conséquente de six mois payer avec une
augmentation de leurs compétences donc
lé véritable avancée mais si on leur et
faire vraiment au sujet de la retraite
les personnes risquent de travailler
deux ans de plus et ça pour les
personnes sur lesquelles on ne peut pas
agir sur les conditions de travail il
faut qu'ils puissent continuer à partir
avant et donc au même âge
aujourd'hui on parle de pénibilité on
parle de fin de carrière
moi je dis depuis le début pour la cfe
cgc que ces sujets sont dans l'agenda
depuis des années le gouvernement pour
des raisons d'opportunité les a remis
dans le sujet à l'occasion du débat sur
les retraites et surtout de la
mobilisation sociale qui lie à contre
son projet donc je serais extrêmement
attentif à ce que la nécessaire
évolution positive sur les questions des
fans callas de la pénibilité soit prise
en compte de manière correcte
indépendamment de la question des
retraites qui est un sujet d'ordre plus
général
je pense que le printemps arrivera que
l'on n'aura pas terminer ce cycle de
réunions au qui parfois nous amuse un
peu et surtout nous déprimer voyez que
les syndicats sont loin d'être tous
optimistes quant à l'issue de cette
énième réunion en tout cas le premier
ministre edouard philippe doit faire des
annonces durant cette entrevue
et puis à l'issue de la réunion il fera
des déclarations
donc nous suivons la situation ici
devant matignon merci beaucoup katia
technique en direct donc de paris